I like to scream Porto Rico and that's
about it I'm expecting beans and rice
since it's a u.s. territory I think it
might be very American I mean
dissipating a lot of spice oh I never
thought about is it gonna be spicy it's
gonna be crazy
looks like a cracker of some kind with
the jelly on it
frozen jelly this is guava and this is a
cracker the first thing to explain to me
but it tastes so good with the fruity
thing it's got like this sweet salty
combo this is what I would even I was a
kid and my mom just wanted me to shut up
she would give me stuff like this like
fried potato with meat inside of it damn
Wow
can we get this for lunch yeah this is
fantastic the potato is kind of thicker
it's a lot of potato for me I reckon my
not already - this looks like raisins
which makes me very nervous no their
little black beans with yellow rice it
was good it's not as spicy as I thought
it would be it's almost like you're
questioning if there is even a hint of
spice a little oily for my tea I don't
mind it I would put some salt on this
[Music]
what did you just call me that sounds
like an elephant in a Disney movie I
realize the pork the plantain is really
dry the pork is very subtle it's not
like overpowering me like what we're
used to
this could use some salt which is so
good I'm gonna need my first child
mofongo
[Music]
it's mostly good Krispy Kreme donut its
how does not like the churro you gonna
drink the whole thing
whoa it was great I would definitely
think there's rum in here cuz it's a
creamy drink it's really bland the
coconut taste is just just two more too
much coconut like just enough cinnamon
too so this is only served during
Christmas this is actually good we need
to replace eggnog with this I would go
to Puerto Rico just for this you've
impressed me poor Torito you have
impressed me I have been impressed by
the mofongo I loved it it was great
[Music]